ich muss mal was fragen sie wo finden
sie wir sollten jetzt einmal die folge
beenden weil wir schon bei über 20
minuten sind wollen wir auch bei mir
vorbei gucken
so kommt der neuen folge minecraft hero
ich bin aber leider nicht mit dem spiel
seine den crafter und ihr euch weiß gar
nicht richtig was hier abgeht
herzlich willkommen zurück ich gucke
schönheit falsche richtung hier
wir sind doch nicht statt rot bei denen
alle richtig ist eine wundervolle
begrüßung von ist ich möchte aber erst
mal ist man töten hier wasser durch
löcher gestorben genauso wie mit dem mit
dem bären damals den willst du mehr
anstupsen oder kosovaren ganze brennen
und 30 verweist auch hier
ach so ja doch die prüfer dass ihr war
dass der krieg war ich höre ich
vielleicht im hintergrund so genau so
wie wir eine bewegte darf sein privater
homepage
du hast ja wieviel schaden der dir
gemacht hat ja gut er wolle sich jetzt
das angebot bereiten oder willst du
dafür mit in unserer stadt kommt ich
weiß du dir nix in eine stadt zu
kopieren weil du hast es gerade noch 10
leben ja ok willst jetzt mitte man hört
doch jetzt auf den am ende hinter den
frieden gebe zu die richter geben wir
wollen weg gehen das heißt das werk in
den nacken unterbreiten willst gehen wir
natürlich in deine stadt lieber okay
dann braucht eben ein blog über mir
damit ich mein spiegel
ja das findest du natürlich hier gar
nicht gehen haus rein denkt so das blog
darüber wer hat wir wollten ganzen
häuser das voll cool also manche baut ja
also mal so hat auf jeden fall gebaut
aber es auch andere ich weiß auch nicht
wer ich möchte nichts keine namen nennen
ansonsten weil sonst vergesse ich bloß
welche jetzt an der stelle
ich habe da ich immer angst dann wenn
ich sollte mache weil ich denke dann
immer scheiße ist unheilbar blog über
mir und dann kann ich kennt es ja auch
ist immer sehr doof ich brauche den
ersten flug zauberstab für mich nein ich
sage ich dann keine mehr
als ob deren design ziemlich verbraucht
ziemlich verschwendet weil du hin
gesprintet bis zur magic the sense of
magic ist enzen stuff heißt es einfach
glaube ich okay ja es möglich das so
heißt im moment müssen wir ich sehe dich
komm zu mir mit in die pause
bleib bei mir ich hab die ganze zeit in
form
ich will der allerbeste sein die keine
von iran ging ging er weiter ist der
pokémon um zu verstehen
nach breaking bad
lena kommt hier rein ja über grund kam
auch sehr gutes vergleichen die beiden
serien dieses erst vor was da steht
jetzt kommt ein bisschen
emotionsgeladener bitte hier
mehr weniger ein bogen aus sachsen mit
emotion freu dich hier zu sein
nur den ich bin in friesoythe mit
größerer batterie als [ __ ] pergament
rheinländerin
ich hab dir hab noch gar nichts um
schlagmann machen doch nicht zu schlagen
hier auch was zum schlagen aber bestimmt
komitee hoch mit was kannst du mich
erschlagen den diener gene
ich verbrenne nein du hast vorhin
resistent dritte stell dich mal ganz
kurz vor wer bist du du bist der von
stadtrat ich lebe der firma man nicht
will nicht mein helm abnehmen habe ein
bisschen angst dann hallo
hi stell dich weiter vor ach so was ist
denn mein name ist eng mit china
ich bin diktator amtierender diktator in
stadt und ich wurde zum diktator gewählt
jetzt schaffe ich das wahlrecht ab damit
niemand anderes meinen posten einnimmt
ich habe derzeit paar probleme mit dem
untergrund das team von vier abtrünnigen
meiner sicht und worden und gut dass du
darauf zu sprechen weist hast du sonst
noch probleme mit irgendwelchen
minderheiten also neulich je hast du
nicht okay nur der untergrund okay wir
sind ja jeder über grund dementsprechend
neulich gleich hat mich geärgert
ja ja sie hat mich nicht getötet haben
ein bisschen angegriffen
wenn du so ja ungefähr so ja das ist ja
nur freundschaftlich also lass mir
gerade so ein bisschen an der grenze man
wusste es nicht also meinst du auch
vielleicht dann so als ich dich
geschlagen kam so etwas braucht es aus
der sprachbox wird wahr ist
es war die überreste blizzard mann
naja gut egal
als wir sich eine über grund und kinos
hat uns zurzeit so positioniert dass wir
erst mal wie die schweiz sind
dementsprechend wir warten ab als ihr
seid ihr über gott das hat nichts mit
untergrund überhaupt nichts mit dem
untergrund zu tun der untergrund hat
auch nur uns den namen geklaut weil wir
der über grund existiert eigentlich
schon viel länger als er unter grunewald
weil der über rund acht sekunden richtig
gefunden und wir video schon sagt
erfunden wir sind die schweiz ihr mega
weil wir uns bisher noch nicht
positioniert haben es sieht wieder auf
die gesetzlich fixierte schließt eine
auge immer wenn du darauf bist nicht
mehr du schießt den augen mich was
impact of custody 1 rast funktion
aktivieren nein möchte ich mich nur
bitten also so gut wir haben zurzeit
noch nicht positioniert aber ich hab
jetzt gedacht dass ich das mal einfach
in die hand nehme
mit zusammen weil wir beide haben das
einfach mal so für den ganzen über grund
haben wir beide jetzt einfach mal
entschieden wir sind wo zwei leute aber
das ist nebensache haben ja irgendwie
man die komische sachen sowas dann koche
uns beim evergreen so positioniert dass
wir jetzt die ganze zeit entschieden
haben wer für uns die wirklich
demokratischen guten sozialen parteien
könige einfach führende personen im
staate mit dem wir zusammenarbeiten
möchten damals für die heutige hab ich
die zeit kenne den entschieden und lena
wir möchten den angebot unterbreiten
zwei möchten wir mit dir und somit auch
mit pop shop media sein wissen oder
warum stehst du hier nur um einen auf
cool ist jetzt auf gesehen aber ich sehe
nicht ein schwarzer bildschirm
das gut jetzt greife ich an
es waren zwei weil beschießt immer zwei
nein ich habe einen kristlbauer der ist
einfach nur vollständig schießen
deswegen hat er auch mehr schaden
gemacht als deiner okay
nein ich mag mich nicht du hast mich
geschlagen ja ich wollte was
ausprobieren kann ich wirklich noch
schlagen wir wollen mit dir ein bündnis
eingehen das heißt nicht ein bündnis das
du teil des über grundes bist sondern
dass der über grund auf jeden fall mit
dir frieden hat den punkt punkt dass ich
dich jedenfalls nie töten werde
und geht es auch nicht und weil du uns
dementsprechend auch nicht aber wir
werden so in frieden leben davon wollen
wir dann auch noch simple und cap
überzeugen aber es wird wahrscheinlich
nicht so schwer sein aber das kit
familie auch gegen den untergrund
selbstverständlich bereit ja gar nicht
neutral
kommt drauf an wie man neutral
definierte 20 hintergrund das ist für
mich das wichtigste
wie viel gefühl und mit einem paar
leuten sind wir neutral aber gesagt
gegen den untergrund ist sie natürlich
auch verbrecher oder ist sie genau
ja es ist kommt drauf an wie man jetzt
in den untergrund definiert was der
unterhaltung
das ist ja das ist unten halt unten ist
er immer negativ deswegen haben wir uns
gedacht unten liegst du dich mich euch
die e mails um gespielt und komme hd ach
du tust ja ob ihr müsstet ihr müsst ihr
das schon so ein bisschen genau
definieren für mich weiß dass ich auch
so weit okay also bei ihr euch sicher
sein der der kev für den und den den
zombie für den kann jetzt nicht sprechen
der zombie weiß ich dass er wird euch
auf jeden fall ganz gut klar kommen mit
unbespielt et cetera wie ihre kämpfe
weise nicht wieder dich geärgert hat
vielleicht ein bisschen gekitzelt
vielleicht ein bisschen weiße aber bei
kinos und mir ist es so wenn man hier
den über grund am laufen wir sind hier
senior vice president und manager und
booking und werbung und alles mögliche
okay in einem
und jetzt kommt es an wir suchen noch
zeit für einen krieg gegen und den
untergrund dame auf jeden fall zeit
finde jetzt sehen wir uns ja mit ihr
verbinden damit wieder so ein bisschen
dazu markanten mal wünsche über ein blog
darüber laufen noch mal
der kommunalwahl raus nochmal tatsache
und wasser ja weil die texte dafür nicht
fertig ist was macht das mal guck mal
wie man das hier ab das kleine ding ein
schwanz
ich möchte das nicht anfassen
ich bitte dich wasser und lava aus
wasser ich verstehe hitler
doch hätten diese weise richtig komisch
an aber hier zur auswahl hier ist der
untergrund und hier ist der über grund
der diktator und die partys verstehst du
vielleicht ein damaliges zeichen und das
hier ist ja das ist die raupe gepflanzt
wie sie verlassen jetzt die
fertigungsstätte halloween us- präsident
brauchte verschärft bisschen
überraschend luft nur meisten waren an
der frischen luft
nein das ist einfach nur glas da kannst
du nicht durch doch was hast du noch
gefunden im glas ist dort zwei löcher
ich wage ich wage ich warte dich machst
auch einmal und die verhandlungen sind
beendet
nein also wir wollen sich natürlich von
unserem angebot dementsprechend erzeugen
hinsichtlich der ansicht dass wir auf
jeden fall auch gegen den untergrund
sind es mir wenn ich gegen den
untergrund sind bin ich sofort dabei wo
muss ich unterzeichnen
nimmt man besser auf einer ganzen folge
fand ich es lachen bei 14 reinschmeißen
den es nicht was noch mal wenn das nicht
ein zeichen war er ist drin
das ist jetzt das abkommen mit den sand
block im hopper ja aber du musst auch
einreihen werden
okay nicht geschafft
das hier sagt jawohl 2 aber die müsste
soll voneinander so nehme paket sind wir
beide und das ist ja untergrund okay da
der untergrund schmilzt
ja ich schreibe es gut sollte jetzt noch
bis in unsere stadt zeigen hier
die hat mir gezeigt und zwar an der
vorletzten folge und zwar alles sage ich
dir wirklich alles hat er mir gezeigt
kaempfert also alles gezeigt ja hat er
das ja schon gezeigt dass das nur daran
dass gebaut in der folge wo ich war man
kann hier drücken denke das hoch das
erste berufliche probleme
nein nicht so hier was ich zeig dir und
kam unter da drücken
wieso ich sage ich weiß was hast du
nicht weisst obwohl du dieser stadt
wohnst du hatte die hat dressing gebaut
ja sind spezielle blöcke und da kann es
das einstellen dass die rausfahren und
reinfahren und einfach drüber gelegt das
ist eine richtig billige schaltung hier
siehst du jetzt nicht mehr verkleidet es
wäre einfach oben drauf es gibt einfach
drauf wenn es regnet es kaputt abdecken
so ich glaube wenn man wasser übergießt
ich finde es schön abgedeckt
ja das sieht toll aus von crafter weil
ich bin mir auch sicher deswegen ist das
doch der über grund außerhalb der stadt
das gebäude ist wenn ich aber an meinem
haus hat sich auch ein bisschen was
verändert ich zeig dir das mal
er hat mir auch schon gesagt was neues
haus sagt ja das ist das hat dann auch
ganz neue du musst rücksicht haben das
noch nicht so gut aussieht ja weil du
musst chor es ist auch etwas neu und
zwar wie sie sehen sehen sie hier nichts
weil ich an meiner wand herausgerissen
weil ich dachte ja um eine rüstungs fast
kaputt
herrlich eine rüstung ist doch quatsch
laden ist tot
ich hab mir ist einer ausgeraubten mir
einfach sie einfach meine befristung an
ok was mag kann man mit der soko
littmann
du bist circa vier mal so schnell okay
ganz nett kann man hochspringt das
getriebe aber die hab ich nach und
lassen kann man also man ist nur schnell
mit der oder hat die noch spezielle
fähigkeit doch mal hat night vision wie
findest du diese bäume
deswegen immer noch rot
du darfst nicht rein
ich muss mich leider töten du hast meine
rüstung an das ist richtig ärgerlich
kann angreifen gib mir meine rüstung
jetzt wenn du mich liebst geht deine
rüstung kaputt ihr gebt mir meine
richtung aber es machen verbraucher
jetzt mal die folge eigentlich schon 17
uhr eineinhalb minuten
na gut das ja aufgepasst jetzt sagt hast
du jetzt das angebot angenommen die die
ex zb muss ich zustimmen
das heißt er nochmal vertrag die königin
muss auch zustimmen ja dann macht das
mal okay war zu kurz mein handy muss
jetzt aufstehen da kann ich irgendwas
konkret versagen selbst wenn kein handy
geholt
also wenn du meinst dass die königin
bestimmen soll meinst du damit
wahrscheinlich die soko bawag richtig ja
ok
was wollen sie denn die königin fragen
dinner-show kobold die erste stimmen sie
dem vertrag zwischen stadt roth in
vertretung durch diktator king junge
diener dem ersten sowie dem über grund
zu vertreten durch kontraste okay
stimmen sie zu
gute entscheidung hat die letzten auch
gesagt glücklich zeitung also nur eine
frage ja chocobo sehe ich heute mal
wieder sehr gut aus oktober sollte sie
mehr in folgender beisein europa wo die
erste finden sie mich attraktiv dies
sollte aber richtig gut drauf und hast
du ja das würde ich auf jeden fall
machen sagt ja nur positive sachen was
da los mit ihr habt ihr was dem leben
also ich will doch was fragen bist als
negatives sagen okay was ist denn mit
jacob aber die erste wünschst du dir
deinen eigenen tod
wie das wie das liegt auf der hand hat
jetzt wünscht du dir dein tod oder nicht
dass sie umbringen wollen wir dich
umbringen tobago wo er derzeit in frage
sollen wir dich umbringen
wie wäre es mit jetzt sofort alles aber
darf ich jetzt sofort umbringen
das will ihn nicht fragen da fragt eine
dürftige könig nicht töten los fragt fr
ich habe gesagt was ich jetzt sofort
unbedingt auffällig hinaus das ist die
frage
ok ich ziehe ich nur zu finden wir
sollten jetzt einmal die feuer gebeten
weil wir schon bei über 20 minuten sind
im oktober finden sie sollten das
instagram profil von easy aus checken
oder youtube kanal von easy ja bitte
dann guckt einfach mal nach iz auf allen
plattformen dir so kennt und schaute
vorbei das war es wieder heutige folge
ich bin nicht dabei sollen sollen wir
auch bei mir vorbeigucken vorbeigucken
das ist ja ich will sie dir gerade
zurückbringt
ja ich weiß nicht wo dein haus vom haus
weg sein so unscheinbar aus diaz wird
cooler noch hier auf alles alles klar
aber schnell die folge beenden vielen
dank fürs dabei seien sie vielen dank an
kraft der linkshänder beschreibung hat
auch alles aufgenommen und vielen dank
fürs zuschauen